bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
pour débattre d'une éventuelle
candidature d'eric zemmour je rappelle
ces sondages de 8 à 10% alors qu'il
n'est même pas déclaré et son livre qui
sort aujourd'hui regardez ce qu'on a dit
le polémiste
ça va arriver
alors eric zemmour qui s'est félicité
évidemment de la sortie de son livre on
les écoute
amazon n'a jamais lu cent à 15 ans de
présence en france en est à 200 mille
impressions on en a déjà réédité 100000
je suis premier des ventes alors que mon
livre n'est pas encore sorti voilà alors
je m'adresse à vous stanislas rigaud que
pensez-vous de de ce que dit eric
zemmour déjà réédité il a du succès
bonjour merci de recevoir dans notre
émission oui je pense qu'eric zemmour a
raison de se féliciter du succès de son
livre alors évidemment il faudra
distinguer le succès de son livre est
celle d'un potentiel électoral mais
c'est déjà de bons signaux envoyés ces
des nouvelles de voir qu'avec des morts
est encore beaucoup aidé moi je le fais
ça et que beaucoup de beaucoup doit de
voir que son nouveau livre fonctionne
déjà au pire frédéric billet est ce
qu'il ya une dynamique eric zemmour je
pense que vous pouvez pas le nier est-ce
qu'il vous énerve eric zemmour
au m'énerver nom sauve eric zemmour a le
droit de participer au débat
démocratique
maintenant il faut être aussi conscient
qu'il occupe un espace politique assez
vide actuellement la gauche essaie de
trouver le candidat unique pour on
savait difficile la droite essaie de
s'organiser aussi pour une éventuelle
primaire ou pas donc il ya des accords
et des discussions qui sont en cours
donc il occupe un espace politique
évident actuellement et c'est ce genre
de phénomène on avait le pal par le
passé c'est très bien il prend confiance
il prend des points mais on était quand
le débat va rentrer dans l'ue dit figé
et s'il est bien candidat ça va être un
petit peu plus compliqué pour lui
après ce sondage tout à l'heure crédité
pour la première fois de 10% des
intentions de vote dans un sondage
harris interactive à 14% pour xavier
bertrand finalement l'écart n'est pas si
grand selon vous c'est à une stade
rigaud eric zemmour prend des voix et à
la droite et au rassemblement national
enfin les intentions de l'otan puisqu'il
n'est pas encore déclaré candidat
a totalement d'ailleurs cessé ce qui à
mon avis la force d'eric zemmour ce qui
parle aux cigales et or a rassemblé
quelque part a dû partir et je pense
personnellement ça c'est sa force
actuelle c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui
est capable de rallier ces deux
mouvements là c'est et notamment si les
abstentionnistes et
c'est vous des deux lions des brins
ça va au delà de ça c'est pas lui c'est
l'union des patriotes en fait j'en tue
en ont assez de voir la droite perde
voir la droite chuter maintenant depuis
près de dix ans qui ont tous envie de
changer les choses rapidement on voit
bien qu'elle ait l'air et notamment les
candidats qui sont potentiellement en
liste à nous pas d'énormes différences
avec emmanuelle bach dont ils ont des
termes extrêmement dur en campagne
beaucoup moins aux responsabilités et
puis encore on voit bien que de son côté
le rassemblement national n'est pas en
mesure de gagner en cas de second tour
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de ralliement
alors on voit ce que je dis c'est à tous
les élèves serre et qui veulent
appliquer des politiques
comprendre celle est rejointe tels que
mme eric zemmour est d'essayer de faire
passer le cap du premier tour pour
gagner ensuite tous ensemble au second
vous confirmez n'y aura pas de
ralliements s'il se présentait eric
zemmour avec le rassemblement national
moi je ne sais pas ce qu'est réellement
déchire à eric zemmour choisira la
stratégie qui souhaitent se présenter
moi maintenant je vois juste qu'avec les
nouvelles générations z se trouve
formidable c'est on a aussi bien fait
hier j'étais un peu fatigué ce matin on
était en collage avec les militants
génération z il ya aussi bien des
militants issus de la droite
républicaine avec le des militants du
rnd on voit qu'il ya une vraie réussite
entre ces ces deux mouvements qui se
rassemblent pour ericsson hier frédéric
weill et est ce que marine le pen ne
perd pas des électeurs à force de
vouloir trop lisse et son son image de
candidate à la présidentielle
marine le pen est éprise aussi dans un
couple dans un deal est un peu compliqué
c'est à dire est-ce qu'il faut
radicaliser lycée et malheureusement
pour elle ou heureusement pour les
autres elle va perdre sur les sur les
deux plans alors maintenant eric zemmour
vous savez il peut embêter la droite il
peut embêter le rassemblement national
simplement la droite elle gagne à partir
de deux conditions la première c'est
qu'elle soit unie au premier tour ça
c'est une condition importante et moi
j'encourage les candidats à se parler à
se parler rapidement et la seconde c'est
qu'il ait pas trop de me comment dire de
candidature exotiques et eric zemmour
bertrand par exemple n'ont pas de
rigueur 3d bertrand a tout à fait tout à
fait légitimes à se présenter c'est un
homme qui a un passé une expérience qui
était très dense comme valérie pécresse
moi je les encourage à se parler assez
rapidement pour trouver un accord
politique simplement savez moi j'écoute
souvent exe mots parce que c'est un
homme qui est intéressant je me souviens
surtout que il parle souvent de l'idiot
utile dans les élections et pas écouter
ce coup-ci eric zemmour ce sera didier
utile dirais même macron et voyez dans
un peu sympathique un petit peu
compliqué qui dénoncent souvent les
choses et ben ali que rich hill ce coup
ci c'est lui alors on a on en sait un
peu plus un puisque le livre d'eric
zemmour sort aujourd'hui on en sait un
peu plus sur son programme qui tourne
quand même majoritairement autour des
questions de l'islam insane islas rigaud
l'islam l'insécurité est ce que c'est
suffisant pour faire un programme selon
vous
je voudrais juste à monsieur le maire si
je trouvais vraiment et la france en
banque de nos en effet le site d'accord
avec vous monsieur le maire il faut que
les candidats ou les potentiels mais si
eric zemmour décide d'y aller que je ne
vois pas pourquoi il serait pas partie
de l'équation c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas
aux républicains mais xavier bertrand
sont plus et je crois savoir que
beaucoup de militants de ou de
sympathisants élèves sont aussi les
coûts de gestion déléguée concernant les
questions
excusez-moi pierre fabrègue biais là
vous avez un appel à prendre et les
émois dans la primaire non
adhérents à discuter
q tu es je sais pas si avec ses murs
raconte dany bernois qui est bien de
loin c'est très hypothétique quoi qu'il
en soit le savez moi c'est ce que je dis
plus des bulles eric zemmour cette
démocratie ne saurait se présenter
simplement on voit bien difficulté
d'être éditorialistes d'imaginer des
choses avant les grandes théories et
quand on rentre dans le dur et dans le
réel et dans l'opérationnel ça devient
compliqué eric zemmour malheureusement
il a dû
idée il ya des accords beaucoup et quand
rendent dans l'opérationnel et quand on
est élu par soit 2 longtemps ou même
récemment on s'aperçoit que l'on peut
voir des grandes théories mais quand on
a en face de nous des vrais français les
vrais problèmes des grandes théories
c'est gentil mais l'opérationnel et
qu'on fait ça c'est plus compliqué voilà
à l'opérationnel et le concret j'allais
y venir un stanislas rigaux qu'en est il
du programme tout à part
je suis je suis d'accord et d'ailleurs
je pense que c'est tout l'intérêt
justement quoi eric zemmour de discuter
de dialoguer avec le parti républicain
c'est que partie des républicains
aujourd'hui ne sont pas être en état
d'avoir une dynamique mais par contre il
faut le reconnaître ont une grande force
c'était si leurs élus c'est leur
expérience et leur propose nouvelle ère
qui souhaite qu'ils partagent beaucoup
qu'eric zemmour je l'étais justement à
se professionnaliser on se dit mais dans
la politique et de et ce dans cette voie
là alors concernant les après les sujets
il faut 500 signatures pour pouvoir se
présenter et de l'argent
mais il faut 500 signatures il faut de
l'argent moi je ne suis pas dans le
secret des dieux c'est pas si eric
zemmour les cherche réellement à quel
point les cherche cesser les indiens
s'activent mais est ce ce qui se dit
c'est ce que je vois dans la presse
partout mais mais mais j'imagine que
quelqu'un comme eric zemmour va surtout
si la 10 dans les sondages n'est pas
candidat à tirer forcément l'oeil de
beaucoup de maires beaucoup d'élus et
pourquoi pas de certains orateurs et son
côté opérationnel pour une fois nous à
régina à choisel par exemple on dit on a
six mois d'existence aller et on a déjà
donné le militant on a un malade le
territoire qu'ils torrent qui a mis en
place avec des référents département par
département que partout on voit là on
n'est pas aussi bien rodée et une
machine politique classique en revanche
ça commence à ressembler à quelque chose
sans avoir de plan d'aidé ça rappelle un
peu ce qu'avait fait emmanuel macron
pierre frédéric billets qu'est ce qu'il
a de particulier
eric zemmour selon vous c'est un
candidat antisystème il est il a vécu en
banlieue parisienne il est hors des
sphères politico médiatique parisienne
est ce que ça plaît est-ce que c'est pas
finalement l'homme providentiel tant
attendu à droite
l'homme providentiel à droite
je suis très réservé simplement il faut
pas non plus tapés sur zemmour il a
aussi des avantages est en tout cas il a
à cette occasion pour nous s'il met des
débats sur sur la table qui sont des
débats intéressants parfois il ya des
tabous et ma droite sur certains débats
il faut le dire eric zemmour ça
certainement qu'il a libéré un peu la
parole en tout cas il pose le débat sur
la table voilà alors c'est là où ça
s'arrête parce que il peut
intellectualiser grande des références
historiques pour justifier les positions
c'est très intéressant mais bon le monde
a changé monsieur zemmour
malheureusement et voilà donc qu'en
rendant concret ça devient un peu plus
compliqué savez on peut voir des
théories pour les questions économiques
pour les enjeux nationaux ça
d'ailleurs on sent bien que sur sur le
thème de l'économie eric zemmour est
beaucoup moins à l'aise on sent bien que
il a pris en un peu moins les choses le
monde économique c'est très spécifique
vous savez bon on voit bien que les
grandes théories sur l'économie parce
que ça nous échapper un petit peu vous
savez il ya deux types de sujets en
france il ya le sujet sur lequel on a
une réaction donc c'est à dire la
sécurité par exemple où ça ne dépend que
de nous il ya des questions aussi comme
l'économie ou ça dépend aussi du
contexte international de l'économie
mondiale et notre action et est plus
limité donc vous voyez bien que c'est un
peu plus complexe que ce que monsieur
zemmour je veux bien dire espagne sas
rigole mais une réaction
c'est moi je n'ai jamais entendu eric
zemmour ni la complexité des sujets
économiques ni de n'importe quel sujet
encore une fois je le répète je
m'appelle je le dis plus tôt mais le
présent dans la pluie n'est pas censé
être munitions elle n'est pas seul mais
si tous les sujets d'auto je rajoute
aussi le point le plus important à mon
avis c'est qu'eric zemmour s'il est
candidat il sortira un programme le jour
où il sortira un programme il y aura des
mesures concrètes et là on pourra lui
reprocher de ne pas être solide sur tel
ou tel poids en revanche pour le moment
moi je les gelées j'ai lu je les
écoutais sur ces nous pour inquiéter
encore
il a parlé de sujets débattus suis avec
beaucoup de ministres débattront
notamment et je n'ai pas eu l'impression
de le voir perdre au pied sur des sujets
même technique le nayrac celui des
transports avec les douaniers sont des
élus etc ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui perd
pied donc c'était la grande capacité de
travail sa soeur à l'antenne 500 dans ce
monde en cédant ces orages et encore une
fois le volet sortira son programme bois
dans ce cas là le reprocher de ne pas
être dans le concret et
solide
peur d'être
un candidat hors système finalement un
pierre féerique billet est ce que c'est
parce que réclament les français qui en
ont assez de voir un peu toujours les
mêmes se présenter à la présidentielle
est-ce qu'il faudra revoir ce système
non ce qui est certain c'est que le
choix politique était important les
français veulent aussi une offre qui
soit un peu différencié bon eric zemmour
en système
va se détendre
il fait gris non mais il fait partie du
des médias nationaux il est un peu en
décalage c'est vrai simplement en
systèmes c'était pas le rebelle de
l'année
point de vue en tout cas son parcours en
fait quelqu'un qui qui n'est pas
forcément dans l'est dans les serres
privilégié il est il est né en banlieue
parisienne il est issu d'une famille qui
qui qui a vécu en algérie dont tous
assez audible pour les français oui en
tout cas il peut libérer sa parole en
justifiant de son histoire ça c'est vrai
c'est pour ça que je dis que tout n'est
pas mauvais chez monsieur zemmour
monsieur zemmour pose des sujets sur la
table avec une certaine liberté c'est
vrai parce que du fait de son histoire
de son passé son positionnement c'est
intéressant bon en système moi je refuse
un peu le
enfin disons la qualification quoi alors
parmi les propositions d'eric zemmour
stanislas rigaud re franciser le pays
une allusion évidemment au général de
gaulle vous êtes d'accord évidemment
avec sa faute il re franciser le pays et
pourquoi
achetez moi ça me paraît pas évident
alors plus ça me paraît aux gens ça je
crois que c'est un constat qui est fait
à droite par beaucoup c'est que
accueillir c'est bien c'est une chose
d'être là mais bon si on n'est pas en
capacité d'accueillir les personnes et
d'en proposer un hôtel de sociétés à un
modèle auquel celle-ci milices n'a plus
beaucoup d'intérêt en fait plus sociale
si on n'est plus capable de dire aux
jeunes vous vous avez ce sentiment de
perte d'identité
ah ben moi je n'ai vu le début est très
simple de ma vie cgg vêtu jamie chung
petit village de tous les pays de loire
arrivé donc là ou encore c'est à peu
près préservé on sent qu'il ya une une
empreinte justement de notre culture
chrétienne notamment doit arriver dans
des plus grands des cités on se rend
bien compte qu'il ya un décalage énorme
on se rend compte de ce type qui a un
changement il ya des changements
population d'ailleurs qui sont halte
elle-même par jean luc mélenchon qui
parle de créolisation pour que le oui je
pense qu'il ya vraiment une défense de
notre identité à mettre en place et à
mettre un place en étant les des baux et
voter sur les nouvelles dalles ips et
vérité dont le fait avec brio et
efficaces ont bien fait des billets il
ya un autre et ricains qui a parlé de la
déchristianisation c'est eric ciotti le
député des alpes-maritimes qui est
candidat il veut même inscrire la foi
chrétienne dans la constitution
française regardez ce qu'il avait dit
sur eric zemmour
le candidat qui peut gagner cette
élection qui peut troubler le duel entre
monsieur macro et madame le pen c'est le
candidat de la droite républicaine et je
ne pense pas qu eric zemmour pourrait
gagner ce match je le dis aussi très
clairement alors il l'a dit aussi
c'était pas forcément le bon extraits
que si eric zemmour était face à
emmanuel macron il voterait pour eric
zemmour comment ça a été perçu à droite
à
droite la parole d'eric ciotti elle est
entendue mais n'est pas massive un l'on
se souvient de quelques dérapages qui
avait ciotti avant là dessus moi je
partage pas ses points de vue là-dessus
moi je vais clair délégué moore macron
le choix serait pareil seymour je dis
pas je voterai pas quoi mais je voudrais
pas eric zemmour ou alors c est ce que
c'est un problème de la droite
finalement que les sensibilités sont
beaucoup trop large
oui c'est vrai mais c'est un peu
l'histoire de la droite vous savez c'est
aussi l'histoire du parti socialiste
notre intérêt c'est que il ya un accord
politique les gens puissent se discuter
discuter entre eux moi je pense surtout
à xavier bertrand et valérie pécresse
sont des personnes de qualité comme une
belle expérience quand je pense qu'il ya
un ticket à faire ça nous permettra
d'avoir un seul candidat la droite
rassemblée c'est toujours comme ça que
ça se passe quand on est avancé de
rassembler généralement on y arrive et
puis voilà et puis je pense que
malheureusement les conditions de
monsieur zemmour quand les écuries
seront en marche et que le débat va
commencer certainement au mois de
novembre il sera pris en étau par
différentes
différents partis politiques qui ont une
assise territoriale coup beaucoup d'élus
sur le terrain et puis je pense qu'il va
être pris entre tout ça ça va être un
peu compliqué pour lui alors le mot de
la fin pour vous stanislas rigaud et
eric zemmour semble
en tout cas plaire à la jeunesse dont
vous faites partie pour quelles raisons
la jeunesse se mobilise pour eric
zemmour
jetons je pense qu'ils se mobilisent
pour eric zemmour enfin une partie de la
jeunesse en tout cas il faut pas être ok
j'ai médité non c'est parce que la
jeunesse m'obsède pas avec zemmour nous
commençons avec très nombreux mais je
m'en ce siège si elle soutient eric
zemmour aujourd'hui si elle appelle à sa
capture c'est justement pour son
discours de cohérence et clarté et est
par exemple je suis toujours très
surpris longtemps des répliques à dire
qu'ils étaient très bon train quant à
droite comme monsieur zemmour est un
gars comme daniel mach rond même si vous
êtes précisé nationale vous voteriez
passant pour l'huile et le fait savoir
on peut encore voter pour amener le
balcon quand on a à droite aujourd'hui
c'est tout les jeux ce qui m'interpelle
et et d'ailleurs je crois que si
beaucoup d électeurs du parti la butte
un sympathisant ou du tanger jeunes
notamment sont prêts à se tourner vers
la nature comme celle d'eric c'est bon
c'est pour sa clarté sa cohérence et lui
et le fait que ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui ferait de d'alliances avec les
balcons
des raisons purement politiques et
vous avez quelques secondes pour
répondre sur justement le fait que
effectivement des militants de la droite
pourrait voter emmanuel macron comme ils
l'ont fait lors de la précédente
élection
oui on sent bien que caniza et eric
zemmour essai de farid paya ce militant
et les vous savez un peu ridicule bayel
des années en sont la guerre vieux en
paca
oui oui mais c'est anecdotique et puis
quand la présidentielle va arriver vous
qu'il y aura une même de fond tout
savoir dans l'ordre très franchement
loupé assurent les militants aient l'air
en tout cas moi chez moi tous les
militants et derrière n'a pas un qui me
dit je vais suivre avec les égos pour la
présidentielle ça c'est
suivre emmanuel macron
non pas du tout c'est pas ça non non non
non mais l'écurie on va essayer d'avoir
un seul candidat doit tous être derrière
et on pense sérieusement qu'on peut il
était l'élection présidentielle au congo
deux conditions que gmac affiche à
l'erreur maintenant vous savez je pense
que malheureusement le phénomène eric
zemmour dans deux mois on en parlera au
passé on verra cela on vérifiera merci
beaucoup en tout cas stanislas frigo et
merci à vous pierre frédéric billets
d'avoir participé à ce débat en direct
dans la matinale verte et france